hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
changes to usp1788
subvisible particle matter i'm susie
valdez of labrutz and i will be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by beckmann
coulter
life sciences to learn more visit them
at beckman.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting your
questions you have during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speaker tony
harrison
senior marketing manager at beckman
culture life
sciences tony welcome you may now begin
your presentation thank you very much
for that
introduction and welcome everybody to
this
short presentation on the revised uh
united states pharmacopoeia chapter
1788 it's called the determination of
sub
subvisible particle particle matter
as our company name beckman calter
suggests
we did invent the call to counter in the
first place
and we're also the inventor of the hayak
brand of light observation encounters
for subvisible particle analysis
and both coulter and hayek are named in
the revised chapter 178 and 1787
as the preferred tech techniques for
subvisible
particle analysis
now the usp revised these chapters in
response to the increasing number of
biologic drugs in use
and the need to differentiate between
inherent particles
that may be formed as part of the
product characteristics
and also those potentially harmful
particles
that may have been introduced to the
product from sources such as packaging
processing filling equipment and of
course
personnel the focus of this chapter
is on subvisible particles in the range
of one to one hundred microns in size
the hiac light obscuration test remains
the preferred compendium
pass fail test method and backed up by
the microscopic
membrane method where required this
revised chapter introduces
for the first time the orthogonal or
complementary
flow imaging test method as a useful
complementary tool to these methods and
it emphasizes its use for characterizing
the particle load
in in products and how it can help with
forensic examinations
to identify the contaminating particles
to support
product improvement of course as well as
root cause investigations
so here's today's agenda
today we'll take an overview of the
revised united states pharmacopoeia
chapter
178 and then we'll move on to take a
look at the compendium pass fail test
for subvisible particles in injectable
drugs the hayak
light obscuration test
there are multiple usp chapters on
subvisible particles in parenteral
products
and we'll discuss the calibration and
measurement range is covered by this
chapter
we'll take a look at some of the
examples of particles you may find in
your products
and then we'll take a look at the
complementary orthogonal
culture counter and laser diffraction
methods
as called out in the revised
complementary chapter usp1787
so first let's take an overview of the
revised 1788
chapter
the revised one 788 became official
on first of may of this year 2021 and
178
is of course um in the 1000 chapters so
it's
it's a name for informational chapter
compilating complementing the chapters
787 788 789 and of course
as i mentioned or already one seven
eight seven
chapter 788 is harmonized with the
european
and japanese pharmacopoeia chapters
on subvisible particle matter and
injection injections
where the hayak light obscuration method
remains
the official pass fail technique for
particulate matter
but for the first time 1788 introduces
the idea or concept of flow imaging
there's a complementary orthogonal test
to the hyac light obscuration method
and that's the compendial test fail
method but the the flow imaging
um is a useful complementary tool it
provides all focal information
to help characterize the particle
loading products and
it can also be used to help with the
forensic examination to identify
contaminating particles
to support product improvement as well
as root cause investigations when you
have a fail
of the hayek light observation test
1788 encourages users to develop a
strategy
of particle determination in order to
identify the category
if not the identity of the particle
population
so is to build a comprehensive control
strategy
for final production
so now let's take a look at that
compendium pass fail test them
mandated in usp the hayek light
obscuration
technique
the hayak light obscuration test test
method
was introduced to the usb in 1985
and it remains the compendium pass fail
testing method
the hayak method normalizes irregular
shaped
particles into equivalent
diameter results as if they were
circular particles
and this eliminates the human error
issue with microscopic membrane particle
counting
excuse me a laser light shines through a
measurement view volume
and lands on a detector which turns the
light energy
into an electrical signal
the sample under test is drawn through
the measurement view volume
as particles in the sample pass through
the measurement view volume
they block or obscure a portion of the
laser light
and this reduces the light falling on
the detector
and causes the detector electrical
output signal to drop proportionally
by comparing the size of the drop in the
electrical signal to that caused by
calibration beads which is certified and
traceable
the hayak can now report an equivalent
circular diameter
to that particle no matter what shape
that particle is
this allows the hi-hat to be calibrated
with traceable certified beads of known
sizes and to standardize this test test
method
across the industry
as 1788 supports the chapters 787
788 789 it gives guidance on the
recommended sizes of calibration
beads used to calibrate the hayak
counter
although the compendium pass fail tests
in 787
and 788 reference limits for the number
of particles at just
two size thresholds greater or equal to
10 microns
and greater or equal to 25 microns
this revised 1788 chapter suggests there
is value
in evaluating the particulate load in
the sub 10 micron range
and recommends that routine testing
using the higher
light obscuration method be extended to
investigate particle loads down to 2
microns
it's just adding measurements to greater
than equal
to 2 micron and greater than equal to
5 microns are also very useful
and it points out that the measurements
two microns are really
a great indication of the quantity of
protein
aggregates in a biologic
as the chapter for opthalmics 789
also requires particle sizing and
counters counting sorry
at greater or equal to 50 micron it also
suggests that data in the greater than
100 micron range
is useful too so it goes on to suggest
the calibration of the hayak using
tracer traceable spherical speeds
2 5 10 15 25
and 15 microns in size
so on to the recommended library of
particle
data as can be seen by these images from
a scanning
electron microscope particulates are
very rarely
uniformly shaped they're not spherical
1788 recommends a strategy of a holistic
use of a kayak
and orthogonal test methods right from
drug development
and continuing to final product qc in
production
in order to build a library of reference
particle data
to help technicians with particle
classification
risk assessment and even identification
of these particle substances
now the revised 1788 chapter refers to
the complementary
chapter which has also been revised 1787
were made official on the 1st of may
this year 2021.
now 787 recommends that the coulter
counter
and laser diffraction are regularly used
alongside the high
light obscuration test to gain more
information
on particle size and distribution so
let's take a look
at the culture cancer counter principle
although flow imaging and microscope
method are recommended as
orthogonal test methods to the higher
light obscuration method
the revised 1788 chapter is clear
that reported particle sizes will vary
between these methods
due to the different measurement
technologies used
in each case the imperfect well
certainly in light
light obscuration and laser diffraction
the imperfect method of using
two-dimensional information to describe
a three-dimensional object
it's bound to lead to variable results
being reported
with further complications arising in
samples contain
heterogeneous mixtures of particles
i.e a population of varying particle
sizes
now in the culture counter however the
particle
three-dimensional size is measured in
terms of the volume of the particle
a voltage is applied across two
electrodes immersed in a conducting
solution
such as a buffer solution typically used
for
protein therapies the electrodes are
separated by a precision aperture
the sample test is drawn through the
precision aperture between these
electrodes
and particles present in the sample will
partially block
the aperture as they pass through and
they displace a
volume of the conducting solution
in response the culture increases the
applied voltage between the electrodes
to maintain a constant current through
that aperture
and the size of the increase in the
voltage is directly proportional to the
volume of the particle that's
partially blocking the aperture the
culture counter provides not
only the equivalent spherical diameter
but also particle volume and as such the
culture is
very sensitive to small variations in
particle radius because of course
volume measurement represents the cube
of the particle radius
ie volume is four thirds pi
r cubed so any small changes in the
radius are multiplied by a
cube law making them easier to detect
as a volume change
now coming to our last topic today
we'll take a look at our laser
diffraction the third complementary
method described in 1787 alongside
hayek and coulter
now laser diffraction is a
ensemble technique so it measures a
population of particles all at the same
time instead of the other two which is
one at a time
so it gives a distribution of the
particles present in the samples under
test
now one weakness with laser diffraction
used by itself
is that smaller particles and a mixed
tetragenous
particle population of particles sizes
can remain undetected because the bigger
particles
create so much light uh diffraction
so to overcome this the weaknesses lace
diffraction can be combined
with polarized intensity differential
scattering system
which provides particle sizing
distribution information
for those samples containing
heterogeneous particle populations
and this allows for the detection of sub
1 micron particles
in the presence of particles in the 10
to 100 micron
range
so in conclusion the revised chapter
1788
encourages users to develop a
comprehensive strategy of particle
determination
in order to identify the category as i
said if not the identity
of the particle population so as to
build a compound
comprehensive control strategy
the hyac light obscuration test remains
the compendium
pass fail test method and culture
laser diffraction and flow imaging are
recommended as orthogonal complementary
methods
so that brings me to the end of my very
short presentation today i know it's
very high level overview but
i'd like now to open the floor for
questions
thank you tony for that informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so let's take a look it seems we already
have some great questions coming in
tony our first audience member says
thank you for your presentation please
can you explain the difference provided
by the results between the hayak method
and the culture and laser
diffraction methods
thank you no thank you very much for
that question it's a good question
so as we said the hayak remains the
compendium or pass fail test so this is
the one
you're about using your batch release
testing on and it's used for
product release as i said in usp ep and
jp
it does eliminate the human error in
using a manual microscope method which
is superseded to size particles
but it only reports equivalent
two-dimensional particle matter diameter
sorry
the use of this instrument is harmonized
as i mentioned across
usb ep and jp so
the equivalency between the reported
pharmacopoeial test results has been
established between these two
test methods however the culture counter
on the other hand
measures the volume of the particles and
calculates
the equivalent 3d spherical diameter
and this makes it much more sensitive to
small variations
in the particle radius however its
measurement range is limited depending
on the aperture size chosen for the
measurement
so multiple measurements are typically
required
when you have a mixed particle size
population
it also reports particle counts just
like the hayak but the laser diffraction
method on the other hand
is a dynamic particle sizing technique
that can measure
and report particle size distribution
but not counts
in a sample containing particles from 10
nanometers up to three and a half
thousand microns
just from one measurement but i'll say
it does not report particle count data
just distribution
thank you so much tony now if the
compendial pass fail
test particle sizes are 10 and 25
microns
why is the revised usp1788
recommending the hayak is calibrated
from 2 microns up to 50 microns
so what the usb 78
1788 is trying to encourage the
development
of a particle sizing and classification
identification
strategy not just a pass fail compendium
test
so based on knowledge from the
orthogonal testing of particle
populations
in formulations users can build a
picture
of trends within the product population
populations that
may indicate product is trending out of
compliance
before it fails the kayak test
and this warrants further investigation
as i mentioned several times the height
remains the compendium gatekeeper if you
like for
pass fail testing but if you calibrate
and configure it
to report particle concentrations from
two microns
up to 50 microns and above it can give
early warning
of a potentially out of compliance trend
in product quality in manufacturing
and this will prompt further orthogonal
testing to get to root cause
before the product goes out of
compliance
thank you so much tony we have one more
question coming in from our audience
can you please explain why the colored
light scattering
is required to enable laser diffraction
method to accurately report a particle
load of mixed
sizes of course of course
in order to measure the small particles
particularly in a
population of both small and large
particles
you need to capture the side scattering
data from a polarized color
coloured light source and that's what
the polarized
system does this data is fed into the
calculation from the laser diffraction
of the particle population and it allows
the instrument to
know there are smaller particles there
and to accurately report particles
less than one micron in the size of a
mixed population of much larger
particles otherwise you wouldn't see
them
tony thank you so much for your
presentation today would you like to
provide
any final comments for our audience
before we go
thank you yeah i think it's this this
chapter is really interesting because it
changes
um the the view of uh
hayak testing um from just
final qc testing for the compendium pass
fail con
test right through to pushing it
upstream
into the drug development and process
development
space so the hike now should be used all
the way through
and as i said in the presentation
names culture as the as a good
orthogonal test
for more information about those
particles and
introduces laser diffraction uh
which is good for the research and drug
development process development stage
but
also um it suggests that these
culture and lace diffraction can be used
in the gmp space gmp manufacturing space
for particulate analysis as an
orthogonal test
to the hayak in the qc testing
tony i want to thank you again for your
time today and for your important
research
and i also want to thank lab roots and
our sponsor beckman coulter life
scientists for underwriting today's
educational webcast
and before we go i want to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast
can be viewed on demand lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time take care
everyone
bye